il sera opposé à donald trump pour la
présidentielle de 2000 20 tour d'horizon
express des candidats démocrates avec
l'oeil de philippe gelie ancien
correspondant du figaro à washington
mais en pennsylvanie en 1942 joe biden
détient à 77 ans le cv politique le plus
fourni parmi les candidats démocrates
après 36 ans passés en tant que sénateur
du delaware il devient en 2009
l'indissociable vice-président de barack
obama il a déjà tenté sa chance sans
succès au primaire démocrate de 88 et de
2008 considérée comme centriste au sein
de la famille démocrate
il axe aujourd'hui sa campagne sur les
valeurs de l'amérique largement esquinté
d'après lui par donald trump
tu es super joe biden a toujours dominé
les sondages et il fait office de favori
pour l'investiture démocrate
il est modéré et il a de bonnes
relations avec les milieux ouvriers dont
il est issu il est là depuis trop
longtemps il ne peut absolument pas
représenter la nouveauté
bernie sanders est le seul candidat né
avant pearl harbor s'il remportait
l'élection du 3 novembre 2020 il
deviendrait à 79 ans le président élu le
plus âgé de l'histoire américaine
il est depuis plus de 12 ans sénateur de
l'état du vermont et il a tenu tête à
hillary clinton lors de la primaire
démocrate de 2016 place est très à
gauche sur l'échiquier démocrate
il propose de rendre les universités
gratuite d'annuler les empreintes des
étudiants d'augmenter le salaire minimum
à 15 $ de l'heure ou encore d'abolir la
peine de mort les sondeurs le voit comme
la première menace pour joe biden
notamment grâce aux jeunes qui le
plébiscitent largement
la force de sanders ce sont ces
supporters très motivé il défend des
idées un peu trop extrémiste et un peu
trop à gauche pour les états unis
originaire de l'oklahoma elizabeth
warren est une ancienne professeur de
droit est la seule femme parmi les cinq
favoris à 70 ans est sénatrice du
massachusetts depuis 2013 est connue
pour sa combativité à l'encontre des
grandes entreprises dont elle refuse les
contributions pour sa campagne est mise
sur une récolte de petites sommes donnée
par les électeurs
ses promesses de campagne sont la lutte
contre les inégalités
l'augmentation des impôts pour les plus
riches et la promesse de tordre le cou
aux grands groupes technologiques
américains depuis la fin de l'année 2019
elizabeth warren est solidement installé
sur la troisième marche du podium mais
bien distancé du peloton de tête byden
sanders
elle est compétente sur le fond des
dossiers
c'est une experte notamment en matière
fiscale qui est la matière qu'il
enseigne à harvard elle manque un peu
d'empathie une élection américaine
serait incomplète sans un milliardaire à
la table des candidats michael bloomberg
à 77 ans et plus riches que tous les
autres candidats réunis avec une fortune
personnelle estimée à 60 milliards de
dollars
son cv politique tient en une ligne la
mairie de new york qu'il a occupé de
2002 à 2013 sa candidature à la primaire
démocrate extrêmement tardive en a
surpris plus d'un sa stratégie pour
l'emporter et simple des centaines de
clips de campagne payée à prix d'or qui
inondent les médias et les réseaux
sociaux américains
de quoi occasionner un frémissement dans
les sondages mais michael bloomberg est
encore loin d'inquiéter le trio de tête
il est riche il ne représente pas la
nouveauté n'est pas neuf n'est pas jeune
et n'a pas de message clair
à 38 ans pictbridge et là surprise de
cette primaire il y a encore un an il
était un parfait inconnu de la scène
américaine
et pour cause ils n'étaient mer que
d'une modeste ville d' indiana south
bend ce diplômé d'harvard parle cette
langue a fait la une du magazine time
avec son époux et a servi sous les
drapeaux notamment lors d'une rotation
de sept mois en afghanistan
il capitalise sur sa jeunesse et mise
sur un changement de génération à
washington pitbull i djedj émergent dans
les sondages au printemps 2010 9 mai n'a
jamais dépasser durablement les 10%
d'intentions de vote
il est aujourd'hui au coude à coude avec
michael bloomberg
il représente la nouveauté dans cette
compétition et ils les modérés
apparemment son homosexualité affichée
lui coûte des voix dans la communauté
noire qui est indispensable pour un
candidat démocrate
la longue bataille de la primaire
démocrate se finira à la mi-juillet
lorsque le parti décidera d'investir
celui ou celle qui tentera de battre
donald trump dans les urnes le 3
novembre 2009